so as we pick up with the second part of
our spy River series we're going to do
here is again pick up right where we
left off and in the last video we had
seen it as the various Spider Man we're
gathering together as they had I guess
transitioned themselves from the safe
zone to the 29 I'm sorry to the earth 9
to eight universe what we had found is
they had met up with superior spider-man
and various others but at the same time
they had encountered a mo so he
basically followed them to this
alternate reality and what we do is we
pick up with this we pick up with damos
as he's attacking these various version
of Spider Men and of course what we see
taking place is that these different
spider-man and spider-woman are able to
oppose demos and ultimately alongside a
superior spider-man some of the other
spider-man are able to effectively kill
demos and so what happens is we see that
the group begins to try to figure out
what's going on but Peter Parker says
that this is necessarily right that
something isn't seeming to to fit in
here and the reason isn't necessarily
because they killed a MOS and true they
didn't really have a choice they were in
a situation where it was either damos or
then the reason Peter Parker says this
isn't right is because the bodies of the
inheritors are of more lune in his
experience disintegrate when they're
killed but this hasn't happened yet this
body hasn't disintegrated this body is
simply just laying there now initially
superior spider-man says this is not a
bad idea and keep in mind here this
version of superior spider-man is Doctor
Octopus in the body of Peter Parker and
so what superior spider-man says is that
this is a chance for them to analyze
this body to analyze the physiological
and the biological body and to see if
there's some kind of a weakness they can
exploit and ever in their efforts to to
try to go against the inheritors but
again before they're able to get too far
into this we see that old man spider-man
shows up and tells them that they don't
really know what's going on here they're
kind of fumbling around in the dark and
that he's really the only one that has
the answers now initially we're
expecting to see him chime in and tell
us what's going on to give us the
answers to this but before he does we
see that hands come up from behind him
and snap his neck and what's revealed is
that damos has arrived here along with
the twins and so what we have is a
situation where we have a body of damos
lying on the ground and we have a
version of damo standing in front of us
then what happens is the
while the group is panicking and the
group is trying to figure things out and
trying to understand how this is
happening Ben Riley and Kane come to the
realization that what's most likely
going on here is that he's being cloned
that damos is cloning himself maybe the
other inheritors are cloning themselves
as well which explains the return of
more loon to the Marvel continuity and
so what happens is Ben Riley and Kane
realized that if these clones are coming
out then the clones have to be made
somewhere and so what what Ben Riley and
Kane realizes that they can basically
trace the source of where these clones
are coming from and they can open up
portal to that location which they do
but what we also see is that a Jessica
drew from the ultimate universe says
that she'll follow them as well now
initially Miles Morales is a little
hesitant about this he doesn't really
want to see Hurley but what she says is
that there's really no choice here this
is a situation where she has to get
involved but what we do is we pick up
with other group as it begins to
basically split her off in this same
fashion they begin to move away and in
different directions we of course see
that spider-man UK opens up a portal
back to the safe zone and initially the
earth-616 Peter Parker tells Miles
Morales that he needs to leave to go
back to the safe zone along with Peter
Parker himself before Peter Parker can
actually do this before he can leave old
man spider calls Peter Parker towards
him and what we find out is that old man
spider is actually Ezekiel stems from an
alternate reality where Merlin had been
successful in killing Peter Parker and
so as a result
Ezekiel Simms in this alternate reality
had the suit of Peter Parker or I guess
a Spider Man made and began carrying on
the role of Peter Parker in his name but
what he tells Peter here is that above
all things Peter has to protect the Sion
the other and the bride now this is
extremely important because what this
does is it's basically Marvel telling us
this is not going to be your
run-of-the-mill spider-man story anymore
this is not going to be a situation
where some characters just get together
they fight a villain and then done and
done instead there's a much deeper and a
far richer story going on now as far as
the sigh on the other end the bride we
know that for the most part silk seems
to be the bride here in fact we see
spider-man commenting to Ezekiel Simms
saying that Ezekiel Simms is constantly
referring to silk as the bride the other
is most likely Cain as far as we know
this particular spider-man that we had
seen Scarlet Spider when we first met up
with Deimos
at a wondercore mountain but the Scion
is a character that we don't know yet we
don't know who that character is now
what's interesting here is we've seen
this character before we just simply
don't we don't have it we haven't don't
really have a reason to connect the dots
we haven't been able to put these two
people together yet and so what we do is
we see that as Peter Parker is talking
to Ezekiel that silk steals his portal
device and the reason why is because
again touching back on what superior
spider-man had said superior spider-man
had commented in the sense that the
inheritors seem to be able to track down
silk more than anybody else and so
because of this silk has really taken
and on our personal quest to somehow
find a way to distract the inheritors
and to lead them away from the other
individuals of the spider team now I
wouldn't go as far as to say that this
is anything like a hero complex so much
as it is so really genuinely believing
that she's the one at fault here and so
what she does is she opens a portal and
she calls out to Deimos and the twins
and then she jumps through this portal
now Jessica drew initially I guess
involved I guess Jessica drew from the
earth-616 continuity initially I guess
volunteers to follow silk through this
portal but we also see the superior
spider-man
since spider-man noir through this
portal as well and what this does is
this kicks off the Spider Woman
I guess the spider women tie and what
we're going to see is that this roster
that is to say spider-man waar and
Jessica drew were actually going to be
replaced by two other characters which
will really round out the name of the
Spider Woman tie-ins but again what we
do is we see that Peter Peter Parker and
the rest of the group along with Miles
Morales and superior spider-man are able
to escape back to the safe zone and when
they get back there we see the superior
spider-man says that this is a time of
war this is a time when somebody has to
take an authority position and that
because of this he's basically made
himself the person in charge and so what
we do here is we jump to the first high
and we jump to the actual Spider Woman
tie-in and what we do is we pick up here
with Jessica drew against spider-man
waar and silk and what's happening is
when they arrive in this Rihanna they
seem to have been here for maybe a
little bit that is to say they've
basically been sitting here for a short
amount of time and it seems as though
what's basically happening is Sokka
simply jumping through realities here
and this is the reality that she first
ends up and
now Marvel doesn't give us a numerical
designation for this reality and the
reason why is because when it comes to
stories involving alternate realities
when Marvel does not give a numerical
designation it means that either the
group is not going to be in that reality
very long or that reality doesn't matter
and that's exactly what we see here
we're given a little bit of context here
that is to say we learned that this uh
this reality seems to be maybe dystopian
in nature that there's still some kind
of City off in the distance it's made of
gold but we're not actually going to
travel there what we see is that almost
immediately after this group arrives
here that they're followed by the twins
and the twins immediately launch an
attack against a Spider Man noir against
Jessica drew and silk now initially
Jessica drew and silk were able to
overcome the twins or at the very least
hold their own but spider-man Noirs
injured in the process and so what
happens here is Jessica drew and silk
take spider-man waar back to the Marvel
noir reality back to this alternate
reality and the whole reason for this as
Jessica drew explains is because
spider-man waar has friends here he has
people that can take care of him people
that can tend to him but they can do it
discreetly that is to say with no real
questions asked and so what happens as
this group is going about and this group
is talking is there some kind of a noise
outside and their initial belief is that
perhaps the twins have already followed
them which again makes sense due to the
fact that they can so easily homed in on
the signal asila when they get out there
what they realize is that this is not
the twins that instead we see the
earth-616 Peter Parker who's accompanied
by Anya from the earth-616 continuity a
spider girl as well as spider-gwen and
what Peter Parker says is that they're
basically taking Jessica drew off of the
detail for following silk and the reason
why is because a spider-man says there's
some kind of a of a I guess a situation
going on here there's some kind of a
course of action that needs to be taken
but that Jessica drew seems to be the
only one who's able to fulfill this role
and so Jessica was a little angry about
this she's angry about the fact that for
her and this really holds true to the
Marvel continuity she was the first
spider girl or Spider Woman she was the
first female to undertake the mantle of
being a version of spider-man and so as
a result she has the most experience
here and again given the history of
Marvel continuity with the earth-616
universe this is true Jessica drew is
the first spider
and so she says that she's basically
being replaced by a couple of teenagers
but what happens here is once she
accepts the I guess his position that's
being given to her this mission that's
been given her by Peter Parker
she calls Anya and Angwin Stacey to her
side as she began speaking with him and
what she tells them is that silk is
Rekha's reckless that silk will make
headstrong decisions that she will be
foolhardy and she will not think things
through and as a result if they allow it
to happen that silk will ultimately get
to get them killed
now silk overhears this conversation
she's actually heartbroken by this and
so what happens is that Jessica Drew and
spider-man depart to presumably go back
to the safe zone so Jessica drew can
learn about her mission and then we find
that when Anya and Gwen Stacy arrive or
I guess to go back to the inside of the
building to to find out what's going on
with silca silca somehow disappeared as
she's somehow taken off leaving the two
of them behind with that being said
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly